Intel was on the money Oracle of course
it's the p8 it's definitely another
metahuman trafficking lab but is it
bedlam I'm seeing pots full of black goo
sounds like a match the bedlam uses a
substance called tar as a catalyst for
turning abducted meta-gene kids into
full-on metahumans assuming they can
survive the process then let's shut them
down
[Music]
yeah
wait night wait do you read worried
about me worried you didn't get a sample
of the tar before you blew the place
wait ahead of you sending data now got
it running analysis okay this is crash a
solid lead to the source of the tar and
hopefully bedlam central spoon tar
contains a clay only found in one place
markovia with in markovia here we come
[Music]
and we have producers Greg Weisman and
Brandon Fayette II here joining me on
the couch to talk about a hello boys how
are you very good so let's talk about
what what exactly did we just see in
that clip which was awesome well you saw
Dick Grayson Nightwing out of costume in
what we were calling dark wear because
he is in Russia where the Justice League
is not allowed to go and so he can't
wear any superhero symbols or anything
like that and he's on the wire with this
mysterious female voice Oracle big
reveal yeah that's a huge reveal right
there really so we're gonna see Oracle
and the series going forward or just
here we're definitely gonna hear like
our secrets what was it like to reopen
the doors on the franchise like it was a
something that you guys ever thought
you'd see come back in your lifetime or
something you'd be working on again I
wasn't sure to be perfectly honest and
you know we have the the fans to thank
for that there's support helped bring us
back so right so yeah people love this
court they really did they got behind it
they got on social media and they talked
about it they spread the word and we're
back the hell out of it yeah so it was
great for us to come back to it and you
know reopen all the stories that we
didn't quite get to in our second season
and it was like kind of like getting
back together with old friends to kind
of you know get the cast back together
and bring in some new cast as well it
was a new cast can you say no you're not
gonna be honest um we've got Troy Baker
playing geo force right on he's
fantastic
we've got Jason Spisak playing forager
no fourth world yes
Sarah Fazal is playing halo and who am i
skipping there's there's many more
anymore and we're holding back alive
because we want people to discover the
show through the show we don't want to
announce everything up front up front no
doubt let me ask you as am asking
everybody that comes through what's in
your universe respectively well I mean
I'm old so I go back I mean I think in
my first first comic I ever read which
was a
to sleep justice society cross over and
how cool that was and and you know I'm
really excited that people be able to
read The Young Justice companion comics
that we did and Captain Atom and other
stuff that I've worked on over the years
but also that things like the crystal
reef Superman and and that Chris Adam
West man and Adam West family those two
like you know when you mentioned him
some young kids roll their eyes and
stuff they're like hey man Ben Affleck's
Batman but it's like at one point for us
Adam West was Batman those two
franchises were so formative than minted
many heart fans and Lynda Carter is that
third one man the triumvirate the
trilogy if you will what about you
what's in your universe
Superfriends yeah yeah that was my intro
to the DC Universe was it that's the
first time you saw the carrier's time
yeah yeah and then of course later on
time and the animated series hey
everybody it's Charlie we got brand new
Young Justice season three to talk about
and premiere date because we found out
the way that they're gonna be dropping
all these episodes so I'll explain
what's going on if you're brand new to
the channel there's a new round of that
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video I'll be sure to
name a winner at the end of this the big
thing about this clip and the funny
thing about the way they explain it is
this basically Nightwing in Oracle and
you know the way Kevin Smith was talking
about it is like will we get to meet
Oracle and get to see her on camera the
way they played this like people don't
know that Oracle is Barbara Gordon who
is Batgirl on the series is kind of
funny and these are just trying to have
a little bit of fun but if you remember
at the end of season 2 Batgirl has
started to do more computer-based and
detective work things that she does when
she's Oracle so it was just them
foreshadowing that that's what her
character will become eventually no idea
if she's Oracle full-time or if she'll
also still be doing Batgirl stuff but I
don't think they've gotten full Killing
Joke or anything like that so I'm
assuming that she still has the ability
to walk and she's just operating as
Oracle using that code name because of
what they're doing so the other
important thing is that they explain why
it's called Young Justice Outsiders
because yes they're doing outsiders
characters from the comic books but the
thematic reason is because they're
operating outside of the purview of the
just
I like the way they reference Russia and
this too like he can't wear any
superhero logos because it'll cause some
big international incident which is why
Superman Wonder Woman and Batman can't
come to help out so there's gonna be
doing some really shady stuff that the
regular Justice League can't get
involved in because they're too
high-profile the deal about episodes is
because they revealed that they were
going to be dropping till after Titans
and then they just announced the Titans
premiere date and said that they want to
release original content new every
single week meaning that they'd be
airing Titans episodes once per week
which also lets you know that they're
gonna be dropping Young Justice episodes
once per week not starting before
January but if you look at the actual
dates for when Titans is premiering
there's 12 episodes they're literally
gonna air their finale on December 28th
that's almost my birthday so it's kind
of crazy that they're airing new
episodes that late in the year
Gimli was the one that said we're gonna
release new original content every week
which is their original shows like Young
Justice Titans and Doom Patrol and all
this other stuff that would mean if they
don't take a break then that next week
is Young Justice season 3 episode 1 and
that would be January 4th if they keep
that Friday day but no idea what day of
the week that they would drop those
episodes on yet they'll probably release
more details about that but until we get
different information just assume it's
gonna be one of those first weeks in
January when that starts dropping it is
26 episodes for season 3 they broke it
into two different blocks of 13 so I'm
assuming they're two different arcs
they'll air 13 weeks of Young Justice
season three then I believe its Doom
Patrol the Harley Quinn show and then
the second block of 13 episodes of Young
Justice
they don't have hard dates on those
other TV shows so just assume that
they're gonna break those 26 Young
Justice season 3 episodes up into two
different parts of the year but as we
get more details about that I'll post
new videos remember the beta for this
open September 15th Titans doesn't drop
til October 3rd at New York Comic Con
then regular episodes will air on
Fridays starting October 12 right now
they're giving you three months free for
the entire year so you basically get
like a huge discount for all the way
through all of young justices season if
you sign up now by the time we actually
do get to Young Justice season 3
you'll have to pay full price so it
actually does make more sense to sign up
now if you do want Young Justice season
3 episodes when New York comic-con gets
here we'll probably get some more
details so I'll do new videos around
then but leave all your requests in the
comments below
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big video Oscar Rider
please email me on the back page of my
channel so I can get your contact
details click here to rewatch the full
Young Justice season 3 trailer and click
here for that teen titans season 6
teaser thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
you